l'ancien groupe scolaire a laissé place
à une nouvelle résidence le quartier du
pont du routard poursuit sa mue cette
nouvelle résidence est composée de 49
logements
c'est une résidence qu'on a acquis en
vefa en pente en état futur d'achèvement
auprès d'eiffage qui ces composants
trois plots nous avons acquis deux plots
pour re du parc social et un plot qui
est uniquement en accession à la
propriété chien alors l'un des
programmes et mixe avec du logement très
social social et intermédiaire et
l'autre pro il uniquement logement
intermédiaire une nouvelle étape dans la
rénovation du quartier lancé en 2006 une
volonté de la commune de dynamiser ce
quartier né en 1974
c'est l'idée de construire la ville sur
la ville on a construit donc de nouveaux
logements
une nouvelle école une clinique tout ça
voilà tout toussaint tout est là donc
c'était une des parts l'avant dernière
tranche de cette opération donc 250
logements qui était construit sur
l'ancien emplacement de l'école de sa
prochaine étape de cette rénovation une
résidence intergénérationnelle qui
devrait voir le jour en 2018